this video was made possible by Shopify
the platform rehang went over and
hundreds of thousands of others online
stores the last five years have been the
most consistently profitable and
financially successful years ever for
the world's commercial airlines
including the 2019 forecast they've
earned more than a hundred and sixty
billion dollars in combined profit over
this period with a world economy more
robust and connected than ever the
aviation industry is flying high or at
least most of it in these same five
years the world has seen some extremely
high profile airline collapses and the
frequency of these seems to only be
picking up the trend truly began in 2017
when monarch a well-respected British
leisure airline with 50 years of history
went belly-up the very same month Air
Berlin a massive airline with over 8,000
employees and 100 planes also ceased
operations 2018 then saw the end of
primary air an airline that generated
buzz but seemingly flew too close to the
Sun in its final days with its low-cost
transatlantic flights and cobalt air a
small chip Riyadh Carrier 2019 though
was the year of slaughter Wow air a huge
player in the low-cost transatlantic
market stopped flying yoga Ezio Frances
second largest airline stopped flying XL
Airways France a long existing
transatlantic airline stopped flying
Adria Airways a mid-sized Slovenian
airline stopped flying
then after 50 years of history Thomas
Cook Airlines suddenly - stopped flying
and would enter the record books as the
largest UK airline collapse ever worth
noting is that the affer mention
airlines are not cherry-picked names
it's certainly not the definitive list
of airline collapses in the past three
years but they are most all the
highest-profile ones and with these
there are two interesting patterns
firstly every single one of these
airlines is based in Europe secondly and
perhaps more strangely every single one
of these airlines with the exception of
WoW air stops flying in either the month
of September or October
neither the pattern in location or times
of these collapses is a coincidence
there are very good reasons behind these
for the timing you see in general
Airlines is most profitable season by
far is summer since that's when there's
the most demand there are certainly
exceptions to this rule for example an
airline flying between the northern and
southern hemisphere a substantial amount
like Qantas typically sees more
consistent month-to-month profits as it
benefits from the demand in both the
northern and southern summer the
seasonality of demand also varies
significantly by region for example here
are a few years of overall
month-to-month passenger figures in the
US you can see there's a clear peak each
August and a clear valley each February
with smaller secondary peaks each year
for Thanksgiving and Christmas if you
take a look at your UPS month-to-month
figures though you can see how
relatively stable the US is traffic is
relying much more on leisure demand
which is highly seasonal European
airlines have to cope with winter demand
being almost half that of summer demand
airlines in the US though carry more
business travelers in proportion who
tend to booked more consistently
throughout the year and therefore they
don't have as much excess capacity in
the winter there are even regions like
Asia Pacific that see nearly no
seasonality in their demand but the main
thing to know is that Europe has highly
seasonal traffic which means the timing
of when its airlines make their money is
highly seasonal for example take a look
at Ryan airs quarterly gross profit
graph in 2018
they made 901 million dollars from
January to March one point four billion
dollars from April to June then an
enormous 2.1 billion dollars from July
to September the fall was then
definitively their weakest quarter with
only 877 million dollars made
essentially they made three quarters of
their profits in half the year the
problem airlines then have though is
cash flow for the busy summer season
airlines will get paid for tickets in
the months leading up to those flights
therefore most of the money for that
season will get to them between March
and August it's there for a season that
can typically sustain even the
financially weakest airlines come
September though bookings start to dry
up and therefore so does cash flow with
that airlines will start to struggle to
pay off their debts let alone the cost
for fuel and other operating expenses
once an airline starts to fall behind on
their debts it tends to be a vicious
cycle quickly they might have planes
repossessed switch
they have to cancel flights which means
they have to pay for hotels and
penalties and for rebooking and pretty
soon the airline won't have enough money
to operate and will be declared bankrupt
in Europe unlike the u.s. there is
little opportunity for business to
restructure went bankrupt so for the
most part that means they're closed down
immediately and indefinitely as the
aviation industry is so volatile and
capital intense these bankruptcies can
happen impressively fast in Thomas
Cook's case there had been hints of its
financial difficulties for months but at
the end of August it seemed the company
would likely be saved by a buyout deal
it only truly became clear that the
airline was headed towards its end the
very week of its collapse but still
everything went on as normal from an
operational standpoint on September 22nd
at 9:40 p.m. the airline tweeted in
response to a customer saying our
flights and holiday operations are
operating as normal that was true at the
time all the flight - were taking off
they were still selling tickets
everything was normal from the public
perspective behind closed doors though
things were not okay five and a half
hours later in the early hours of the
morning of September 23rd the company's
last tweet went out saying we are sorry
to announce that Thomas Koch has ceased
trading with immediate effect all around
the world at the very moment of their
declaration of insolvency flights were
quite literally boarding crews on board
planes fuelled ready to go with a
company now gone though everything had
to stop those crews were no longer
employed that fuel wouldn't be paid for
the planes were no longer owned or
leased by the airline everything stopped
of course once an airline collapses and
its flights are canceled there is no
longer an airline to rebook passengers
on to other flights in most cases
passengers are just out of luck but in
the case of the UK their Civil Aviation
Authority essentially takes the place of
any UK airline for the weeks following
its collapse the CIA will either rebook
passengers onto another airline or just
actually run their own flights of course
the CIA doesn't have their own fleet of
planes rather they have a number of
airlines around the world essentially on
retainer for any time they need to run
repatriations lights this includes
plenty of charter operators like high
fly Atlas Global memos
and more but perhaps the most unique
aircraft used by the CAA was a Malaysian
Airlines a380 the airline dedicates some
of its a380s to charter operations and
so the day before Thomas Cook's collapse
when it became clear that the end was
nigh the a380 flew empty all the way
from Kuala Lumpur to Manchester it
landed a couple minutes past midnight on
September 23rd just a few short hours
before Thomas Cook was officially
declared insolvent as this and plenty of
other aircraft pre-positioned even while
Thomas Cook flew its last flights the
CAA was able to start flying its
repatriation flights the same day and
many passengers were only a few hours
delayed even after their airline went
belly-up
the Malaysian a380 was assigned to fly
flights from Palma de Majorca but part
of the difficulty was that from Palma
Thomas Cook had flown an enormous
quantity of flights to an enormous
number of destinations in the UK London
Cardiff Birmingham East Midlands
Manchester Newcastle Glasgow and Belfast
of course it's much more complicated to
find eight small planes than just one
large plane so that's what they did they
found the largest passenger plane in the
world every flight the a380 flew ran
just the two hours from Palma to
Manchester and then from Manchester
buses ran to Glasgow Newcastle East
Midlands Birmingham and London using
this system with just one aircraft the
CIA was able to run up to three flights
a day from Palma TV UK with capacity for
nearly 1500 passengers the equivalent to
almost seven thomascook a320 once this
whole process went on for weeks making
for a lucrative payday for the world's
charter companies and an expensive bill
for the UK government but it certainly
is easier than having hundreds of
thousands of passengers stranded
worldwide having a record-breaking
airline collapse and then another
record-breaking airline collapse in the
span of two years is certainly not
normal and it's certainly not a
coincidence part of the problem is that
the airline industry has been so robust
in the past decade that it has allowed
weaker airlines to survive out of the
bankrupted Airlines mentioned at the
start monarch Air Berlin primary air
cobalt air Wow air eggless air XL
Airways France Adria Airlines and
as cook five were focused on long-haul
low-cost flying this business model is a
rather new phenomenon may possible at
least on paper by smaller fuel-efficient
long-haul aircraft and low fuel costs
but outside of Asia and Australia no
airline has really achieved sustained
profitability with this model AirAsia X
scoot and jet star are really the only
airlines worldwide that have seen long
term financial success flying the
long-haul low-cost after fuel prices
plummeted in 2014 these airlines entered
a period of rapid expansion as they were
able to undercut the incumbents prices
significantly but then in 2017 fuel
prices started ticking back up and these
airlines had a tough choice they could
either raise prices and lose some of the
market share they had built up or keep
prices the same and grow further away
from profitability many chose the latter
and as fuel prices continue to rise the
companies began to fall many analysts
have also suggested that another
contributing factor to this spate of
airline collapses is over capacity
somewhat as a result of how successful
and profitable the industry has been
over the past decade airlines have been
buying planes like crazy and investors
have been funding airlines like crazy
for a while the rule has been that
adding more capacity means more profits
however the industry has likely found a
ceiling to that rule this is especially
true in Europe's market where buying an
additional plane that you might be able
to fill in the summer means paying for
it throughout the long winter to when it
might stay at empty what's for sure
though is that thomascook will not be
the last to fall it is only getting
tougher to survive as an airline
especially in Europe and each year
without fail another big name too will
topple in September or October the
latest victim in the world's annual
airline calling season one of the ways
that went over productions functions as
a business and stays at a bankruptcy of
course is through merchandise sales we
sell a few types of t-shirts for both
Wendover and half is interesting which
is a nice predictable income source that
we control creating an online store at
first seems daunting but then we came
across Shopify Shopify is a super simple
yet advanced solution to creating and
running your online store they are
designed to be a partner to independent
businesses as features like a logo maker
plug and play store themes marketing
solutions and much more make it easy to
succeed for your customers it makes very
great buying experience one that you've
probably already used as there used by
over 800,000 businesses worldwide
including mine you know in case you want
to try out the buying experience for
Wendover t-shirt by going to Shopify
dot-com slash Wendover you'll be able to
try Shopify for free for 14 days no
credit card required and then after that
pricing is as low as nine dollars a
month